you
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's webinar
you know typing the tumor
microenvironment with advanced tissue
based multiplexing assays presented by
dr. Katie R Patel global manager field
applications ultra view my name is
Chrissy Jewell and with Lavery's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars today's event is sponsored by
Ulta view both of you is dedicated to
research innovation and to delivering
exceptional quality are you Oprah ducts
and services to the life science and
biomedical communities to learn more
about our sponsor please visit Ulta view
com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type in your questions into
the drop down box and click sign if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
our speaker today is dr. Katya Patel dr.
Patel has extensive experience
developing reagent driven solutions for
high definition biological imaging
Institute combining high level
multiplexing at high speed with high
spatial resolution specifically in the
field of immuno oncology prior to
joining all to view dr. Patel was a
product manager for the quantitative
pathology Solutions Group at PerkinElmer
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen now it's without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Patel I will now turn the priests
over to him
Thank You Christy for that wonderful
introduction
so I'm dr. Patel I'm happy to be here
today and I appreciate the opportunity
here with lab roots to tell you a little
bit about what we're doing here at all
of you so just to get right in you know
we're a Cambridge based company we've
been working with tissue multiplexing
for quite a while now we have a variety
of products that are offered to the
consumers that are out there today we
can engage with you in a couple
different ways one way is through our
kits and our custom kit content which
I'll describe a little bit later in our
presentation we also have a services
group that provides custom content as
well if you're interested in higher
levels of flexing or custom fails that
fit your specific needs so just to get
right into our presentation today you
know the first thing we want to really
sit down and discuss is the tumor
microenvironment and why we need tissue
multiplexing today the tumor
microenvironment is incredibly complex
there's a variety of cell types for a
variety of cell to cell interactions
within the immune system and within the
immune system to the tumor understanding
these types of interactions is key to be
able to optimize and understand the best
types of treatments for individual
cancer patients for example one of the
big things that we really need to keep
into account and one of the major
benefits of tissue multiplexing is being
able to understand spatial interactions
so if you look on this slide that's
currently being presented in the center
you'll actually see a figure that was
pulled from the burning Fox lab at
Providence Cancer Center from a
publication in 2017 looking at PDL one
within a tumor when we look at PDL one
alone in within the tumor
you really cannot stratify patient
populations in survival PDL one alone
was not a predictor of prognosis or
outcomes for these specific patient
when you take into account spatial
context with cd8 specifically you
actually get better resolution you can
actually see a stratification of
patients from low to high here as far as
survival goes when CDA was taken into
account in its distance to PDL one now
with when PDL one first really came out
you know this is one of those topics
where if a patient was PDL one positive
or negative that would dictate the type
of therapy that may be recommended for
that specific patient as you've learned
more about PDL one with its interactions
within the immune system we've seen that
now there is much more to that story
than that was initially thought now it's
really important as to where the PDL one
for example is being expressed is it on
the tumor is it on the macrophages and
if so what are the distances is that to
you know specific immune cells such as
CDA these types of key interactions are
things that multiplexing helps you and
reveal in that you can see very clearly
and be able to understand these types of
interactions will allow you to better
understand specific treatments that may
work for one patient versus another
another key to come to kind of
understand with this type of dynamic is
that with with the development of all
these new unique types of personalized
medicine medicine Zoram you know
therapies that are specific to very
unique targets understanding the types
of immune cells that may or may not be
present with each one of these canta
types is becoming more and more
important being able to have a more
unique in critical view of the types of
cells that are present for each specific
tumor type allows you to better
understand which types of treatments may
be more effective in one case versus
another and as far as the tissue
multiplexing goes it's been around for
quite a while and with you know current
technologies that are available on the
market there there's been left for quite
a few things that people would be
looking for to be able to really scale
this type of process just scale the type
of technology and apply it to a larger
group of patients one of the big things
is you want a high level of flexing as
we learn more we need more right that's
a very simple kind of dynamic you want
to be able to flex to the level that
accounts for the types of studies that
you're looking for
some may involve you know two to three
flex to get them information that you
need some may involve 10 to 12 Plex to
be able to get the information that you
need so you want to type of platform
that allows you that type of flexibility
you also want a type of platform that
takes into account the fact that samples
are becoming more and more scarce and
samples are becoming smaller and smaller
so ideally you'd like to have a platform
that allows you to actually use that
single sample for other downstream type
assays and get as much information out
of that single slide as you possibly can
you also want to be having a platform
that takes an account that we have the
ability to do a whole slide imaging them
and full ion analysis in an infancy of
@issue multiplexing this is really
limited to you know fields of view with
smaller regions and this is usually a
limitation of just the software programs
that were available as you can see at
the bottom that is from the data
analysis codes you know that there's a
lot more options out there there's a lot
of platforms that can actually handle
large data in a whole slide context so
then you will take whole side data
allows you to eliminate bias that you
may have by only being limited to field
of view because we know the tumor is
actually quite heterogeneous one of the
bigger things that I think that you know
most people struggle with - with tissue
multiplexing is an assay development you
know you want something that is very
reliable that's very robust that's very
easy to implement you want to fit into
the existing workflows that you know you
are familiar with and work with
equipment that you already have readily
available now our LT mapper workflow is
incredibly simple its same-day results
so I'm staining two results so I mean
you can get it you can get on the bond
rx or you can stay in this assay
manually and it's five and half hours
end-to-end you can go right into whole
slide imaging which can take about 10
minutes depending on your scanner and
you know we work with a variety of
different scanners we've worked with the
zeiss Axios Kanzi one the olympus vs 120
like a versa the vector Polaris where we
don't actually need the multi spectral
aspect of it but it was a whole slide
imager we've also worked with 3d his
tech so we've been able to work with
most conventional whole slide scanners
that are on the market and as far as
image analysis goes
this is really user dependent there's
been a lot of there's a lot of different
and the whole site analysis software's
that are available such as you know
definian halo etc so again real the real
thing to take away here is that we want
to have same-day results you want a
simple easy automated or manual if that
fits your needs better type of workflow
where you can get same-day results that
are reliable and reproducible
now taking you into our FSA overview of
how our technology actually works please
keep in mind that this essay is
extremely simple that we do a single
antigen retrieval step a single staining
step a single amplification step in a
single detection step for our standard
kits that are commercially available
what we actually go ahead and do is
actually we have our primary antibodies
conjugated to unique DNA bar codes each
primary antibody has its own unique DNA
signature so one you know cd4 would have
its own signature C eight for example
would have its own unique DNA signature
and these are very different they do not
interact with each other they do not
share in homology with anything that's
in the human genome they're very
specific and they're very unique to each
antibody so we can actually pertain the
slide with all of our primary antibodies
in a single step and we do a single
amplification step now the single
amplification step of all targets is
incredibly important this amplification
step is a linear amplification method
and all targets are amplified at the
same rate and at the same time and why
why is this important this is important
because this actually allows you to have
a very quantifiable type asset where
these targets are amplified to where you
can really go ahead and see differential
expression of its particular marker high
and a low expressive for example are
very clear to see and it's easy to
compare markers in different channels so
you can compare your cd4 expression to
your CDA expression for example based on
relative expression because all targets
are amplify the same rates same time in
a linear amplification methodology now
as far as stating goes to actually
detect these targets what we actually do
is we actually apply a mixture of
fluorescent probes that are
complementary to that single stranded
DNA barcode I had mentioned earlier and
now you're actually able to hybridize
those imaging strands to that amplified
DNA barcode and actually detect your
specific signals so it's a single
cleared single detection step and the
one thing to keep in mind here too as
well is that this tissue is actually
fully intact this tissue is in
good shape so you can do downstream
analysis with other types of
technologies other platforms which I'll
describe a little bit later
now with that simple type of workflow in
technology I was just describing our
initial kits that we already have on the
market that directly applies to that you
can apply and run in your own lab today
these are the four commercially
available kits a th kit a b c kit a pd
one and a PDL one kit and one thing to
keep in mind is that these tips do not
are not simply limited by the fact that
they seem to be a four-plex they
actually give you a lot more cell
phenotypes than the four markers that
are there this is because we have an
ability to do high levels of
co-localization which I'll describe a
little bit later but as you can see we
don't use any secondary antibodies
whatsoever so you're really at the limit
of detection of a primary antibody and
the nice part about this assay as well
is that these primary antibodies can be
of the same species that give you all my
lowest amount of clonal they could be
rabid it doesn't matter because we do
not use any type of secondary
and to kind of highlight the fact that
this tissue is really well maintained
and very much intact you could actually
do an ulti mapper staining on a single
slide and actually use that same exact
slide and go ahead and do an H and E on
it and now you can actually get an HD of
the exact multiplex fluorescent slide
you adjust stain in a previous step
there's also you know thoughts that you
can go ahead and do things like you know
RNA ish DNA fish things like that other
types of downstream assays so one thing
I want to dive a little bit deeper into
as you know as described before and just
to make sure that we highlight this each
primary antibody has its own unique DNA
barcode with a single-stranded DNA we do
a single amplification step where we
amplify that single-stranded DNA s via
tandem repeats and keep in mind that DNA
amplified target is incredibly
incredibly small this is why we don't
run in a steric hindrance issues and we
can actually do high levels of CO
localization you're really at the limit
of what the primary antibody can do and
as far as labeling goes we use imaging
strands that are also single-stranded
that have fluorophores attached to it
but they're complementary to their
specific DNA barcode one of the unique
parts of our technology is that we can
actually go ahead and remove that signal
while leaving that amplified DNA barcode
behind and now why is that important
this is important because this allows us
to go beyond well beyond four-plex and
go into areas of you know eight-nine
flexible so on very easily without
having the need to do any sort of
spectral and mixing
and to kind of go ahead and highlight
that I'm going to walk you through how
you can actually go ahead and do a nine
color or a eight Plex a say on a save
five color fluorescent for channel
fluorescent microscope so the steps
would all still be very simple and this
is a type of offering that we can
actually give within our services group
or we can do these higher levels of
lectins not sometimes commercially
available for the field yet but it's one
that we do routinely in-house so you
would still do a single antigen
retrieval step single T wax step that
type of step and you would actually
apply all your primary antibodies in a
single cocktail as you can see at the
top so you move you'd pray you'd
introduce all eight primary antibody
targets at the same time you do a single
amplification step where all all eight
targets would be amplifies the same rate
in the same time as I had mentioned
before it when it came down to imaging
what you would actually go ahead and do
is you would apply a mixture of for
imaging strands using a say for example
I could see at RIT CSI 5m s i7 type
floor for these first four targets
imaging strands will actually go ahead
and bind to their first the first four
targets of interest in the tissue that
you want to look at so maybe your CD for
your CD a side of carrot and then CD 20
for example you'll go ahead and now you
would actually go do a round of imaging
where you'd image those four specific
markers within those four channels you'd
remove the slide from microscope you
would actually do an exchange step where
we actually D hybridize and remove those
fluorescence signals from those first
four markers and now we would go ahead
and reapply a new set of for imaging
strands except for these for imaging
strands would be specific for the four
markers you did not visualize in the
first run after this hybridization
occurs we'd actually go ahead and go re
image that specific slide and Co
register the two images and now you have
would have an eight Plex image on a nine
on a basic four channel microscope
without the need to do any sort of
spectral and mixing very simple very
elegant you know if a tremendous
advantage to be able to do this
and easily as well so the thing to keep
in mind here as well that this does not
add a significant amount of time to the
assay so if you want to go from a
four-plex
to say an 8 Plex assay you're not going
to go ahead and go for a double this
staining time from five and a half to
you know say 11 hours you actually only
add about 45 minutes the end of the
assay
so we from a five and a half hour essay
you'd go to just over six hours to get
an eight flex pay flex data and now if
you think about clinical workflows in
research side workflows for
translational research projects this is
much more attainable this is something
that is much more reliable and easy to
implement for due to slide volume and
types of hardware and personnel that may
be available for these types of studies
and here's an example of an eight Plex
asset that was done within our services
group made Plex image of a non small
cell lung cancer okay I just want to
quickly highlight and you know just
having simple workflows and you know
having a kit that's ready to use that's
pre-optimized that is a big benefit that
itself is incredibly valuable but one of
the other things that we take extremely
there was everything extremely seriously
here at Ulta view is our analytical
reproducibility is how robust are our
assays and how can we make sure that our
assays are performing at at the upper
echelon of what's available on the
market today so for example what I'm
showing some data here is the
reproducibility of our LD mapper PD one
kit what we did here is it took 5 serial
sections of tonsils staying then with
our PD 1 kit and then looked at the cell
phenotype comps across each section to
see what the Seavey's were what you can
see here for the total cell counts is
that we have upwards of a million cells
we have just over a million cells here
so that is quite a few cells that we're
trying to analyze and this is tonsil to
keep in mind and what we see for CVS
between cd3 cd45 ROP d1 and cytokeratin
theory of cv is ranging anywhere from
three to five percent now to kind of put
that a little bit in context you know
having CDs that are within 20% are very
considered very very good at
immunohistochemistry having anything
close to 10 to 15 you're definitely one
of those you're definitely doing an
incredibly good job if you're going to
sub 10% as far as your CVS go that is
something that you should be very proud
of that is something that be incredibly
difficult to do but we're demonstrating
here is that this is a readily available
kit that would give you those types of
results and once these and even easily
argue that you know having CVS from
three to five percent across five cereal
sections a tonsil may be more
representative what's happen tsa's in
biology from section a section to
section
more so than variability in the actual
assay itself
now having goods phenotypic cell counts
that's that's beneficial in itself the
other piece that you really want to make
sure you keep in mind when you're
looking at this is that you always want
to have average you want to check your
average signal attends intensity across
those cereal sections and what we're
showing here and there are actual error
bars there they're just incredibly hard
to see I apologize for the resolution
where you can't see those is that you
won't have good solid average signal
intensity across the board for each one
of those sections as what you can see
here that our signal intensity from
section to section is incredibly
reproducible it's incredibly stable
because you do not want to be having to
set custom exposures from section to
section of the section in order to just
to get appropriate images where you can
do solid analysis and do solid
segmentation if your assay is
reproducible or reliable enough this
should be something that's very easily
done and should be very consistent from
section of section and that's simply not
where we we don't we don't simply stop
there
you know we also add other types that
we're always looking for new and
innovative ways to help our customers
and as well as ourselves understand the
performance of our kits and understand
what the dynamic range of our kits is
understand the type of performance our
customers should expect from our kids
what we're showing here is a PDL 1
expression array that was created by
David rims lab at dr. David rims lab at
Yale and what this is actually what this
array actually has is a number of cell
lines that have differential expression
of PDL 1 via activation of promoters so
you're seeing a dynamic range of cell
lines that are expressing PDL one at
varying levels from high to low one two
one and two of the squads are negative
and then three to four two three and
four are low expressive in five to eight
or showing the dynamic range between
those different cell lines there and
nine and ten are basically animals that
saturation is a very high expresses and
you can see by the array here there
they're set up in basically in triple
kit with number eleven at the bottom
being a placenta control and this is a
DAV stain showing that dynamic range you
know it's not always a clearest thing to
see via da B when you're especially at
the lower end of the dynamic range of
which cells are positive which was or
not or sorry which cell lines are
positive which ones are not please keep
in mind that all cells here actually are
positive and though it may not be
readily visible by them you know via
this PowerPoint slide so what we're
showing here was a PDL 1 expression
array where we where this was actually
created by david rims lab at yale where
you know it's a new way of actually
looking at in understanding the
performance of a specific assays
understand the dynamic range of what an
assay can actually detect as far as PDL
one expression goes and these are the
types of standards we're trying to bring
in to all of you now to for customers to
better appreciate what they should
expect for performance of a specific kit
and what we're showing here is a group
of different cell lines that are but
they're all the same cell line that all
have varying levels of promoter
expression for PDL 1 meaning you're
seeing a dynamic range of PDL one
expression for the cells within each one
of these groups 1 & 2 are negative and 2
through 10 show the dynamic range
essentially of this PDL one expression
all cells within these cell lines are
actually positive for the PDL one
expression it may not be readily clear
via you know the PowerPoint slide but
they are all actually positive here and
what we're seeing here is a div show or
stain showing that the stating pattern
of PDL one and that the dynamic range is
there it may not be ultra clear via da B
because of the contrary
when we go ahead and look at this using
our ulti mapper staining kit
specifically for PDL one kit you can
actually see that very that dynamic
frames very clearly very easily and is a
major benefit of using fluorescent based
type staining in this dynamic range is
really important because this allows you
to start understanding what the what you
can actually start to quantitate with
that dynamic range is and understand
what your limit of detection and what
your limit of quantitation actually is
for a specific assay and you know going
back to what I was discussing earlier
you know when we initially started
looking at PDL one you know PL one
positive positive or negative was really
what you're looking at the more we
understand PDL one and its interactions
within a tumor microenvironment we find
out that the amount of PDL one and the
type of cell PDL one is on is becoming
more and more important so having an
assay that is really kind of you know
that is verging on the levels of quanta
quantification by being able to set you
know some curves into some standard
curves using types of controls like this
allow you to understand the lower limits
of detection and how much PDL one may be
important for a specific treatment
protocol and that becomes more and more
important as we develop more and more
immunotherapies and develop these types
of personalized medicines that we were
seeing in the in recent years in
addition to being able to really have a
tribunal a very quantifiable assay and
being able to have an assay that's
really robust where you can see this
beautiful diamond dynamic range of
expression it's also really important to
note that our a phase-in is very easily
able to detect Co expression of multiple
markers on a single cell
now that's incredibly important as well
because this allows you to better
identify unique cellular phenotypes
simply using one marker to detect a
single phenotype is not usually enough
being able to look at very you know so
if you're doing a higher level of Plex
and say you're looking at a Plex or a
nine Plex type panel chances are an
eight or nine flex panel you're not just
looking at basic cell phenotyping you
probably looking to identify a very
unique subpopulation of cells within
whatever tissue sample you're
specifically looking at and usually in
order to identify these very unique cell
populations you actually need to be able
to co localize or be able to detect the
co expression of two maybe three maybe
four maybe even five markers on a single
cells to be confident that that is
specific cell type that you're looking
at and since we're at the basic limit of
the primary antibody we don't use these
secondaries we had we are very easily
readily able to do Co expression to say
in a detect Co expression of multiple
markers on a single cell
so our LT mapper kit for example right
here and when I kind of highlighted with
the T acted earlier you can detect a
variety of cell types from memory cells
to exhausted memory cells to exhausted T
cells in that simply using you know four
markers in this specific panel and to
really go ahead and highlight that I
wanted to show this specific image what
we're looking at here is an FFPE of
melanoma and this is a stain with our PD
one kit what we're seeing in red is C d3
or we're seeing green is cd45 ro and
we're seeing that blue kind of cyan
color is PD one we left off the set of
keratin sox10 during this specific case
to actually keep some clarity it would
just kind of make it a little bit more
difficult to see what we're trying to
highlight here so you have different
phenotypes here and when you have
multiple colors we have multiple markers
being expressed on the same cell you'll
get new colors so if you have red and
green you'll get yellow if you have red
and blue you'll get more of this pink if
you have a triple positive you'll get
more of a white color so we're going to
highlight here is that when you're just
looking around this specific field of
view you can actually see a lot of just
simply c d3 positive t-cells that really
are expressing C D 4500 or PD one you
can also highlight and see some c d3
positive and C D 4500 positive memory
t-cells which have more this yellow
color
you know see exhausted suppressive
t-cells in pink are almost a purple
color which you can see here and then
you'll have some triple positive cells
that you can rarely see here that are
seedy 345 ro and PB one positive in one
thing I also encourage you to look at
within this specific slide is that there
are other cells that are actually
expressing different ranges of these
colors so there are some cells that are
actually more of the orange phenotype
where they're having varying levels of
cd3 versus cd45 ro expression that
they're not very cut and dry that this
isn't a p-- saturation where you're
really seeing the dynamic range of
expression from a cell to cell specific
Kathy case there's some cells that are
most polarized that are half yellow half
green and kind of starting to blend so
you're really seeing that even within
this tissue you're having a range of
expression of these markers from
different cell to cell
so one thing I also wanted to mention
too is that we're going to be at ACR
this year we do have quite a few posters
that will be that will be highlighted
here and that we encourage you to come
down or a booth it's 2048
we'll also be presenting at the leica
bios systems dinner symposium on Monday
April 1st that would be also around a
ACR as well so those are all places
where we would love to come down and see
you and have you interact with us and we
would love to discuss you know any
questions that you may have and
introduce you our technology a little
bit further and I'd like to leave you
with one more image that I'd like to
kind of quickly discuss it's something I
didn't really highlight in the previous
slides just to save a little confusion
but what some of our kids you'll have
noticed that we do a cocktail in our
size 7 channel which is cytokeratin
sox10 and what we're looking at here is
a cutaneous melanoma where you can
actually get five flex data out of one
of our standard kits because since we
put sox10 in cytokeratin in a cocktail
and they stain different compartments
you know sox10 stays a nuclear
compartment stain it's versus
cytokeratin which is more of a
cytoplasmic stain you can actually very
easily do a cell segmentation
using pretty much any analysis software
to actually differentiate two
compartments so you can actually get
five flex data it also allows you to use
a single type kit for you know melanomas
versus a carcinomas and with that I'd
love to entertain any questions that you
guys may have thank you
dr. Patel thank you for that informative
presentation
quick reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click the send button
ok dr. Patel will answer as many
questions as time for Mitch ok our first
question dr. Patel
what if floors do you use so the floors
that we actually use we don't disclose a
specific dyes but generally as far as if
you're going to try to configure a
system to actually look at them we use a
fitzy a Trixie a size five and a size
seven that can all type filter that can
visualize eye dyes and the thing to note
with these is that they're all
spectrally isolated that there is no
bleed through from one channel to
another so that really curbs I need to
have to do any type of spectral and
mixing
next question how many tests can you run
per kit so if you're going to with one
of our kits if you're going to run it on
the bond rx each kit runs 10 slides and
that will be done that you can run 10
slides in up to 2 preps if you run the
assay manually you can run up to about
14 slides dependent on the size of your
tissue obviously you field wiht mas that
will require more reagent volume which
will cut into that total 14 but
gentleman generally anywhere from 12 to
14 is pretty safe
dr. Patel what are the differences in
terms of sensitivity and linearity if
antibody a in antibody be binding ratio
is 10 X 2,000 X what about threshold so
so looking at Margaret a marker yes that
is your binding efficiency of your
primary antibodies can come into effect
but your fluorescence signal should stay
standardized between the two because of
the linearity of the amplification
methodology in our signal of background
regardless is significantly
significantly higher than the background
so when you're actually doing your
threshold you know having very specific
and localized signal is something that
will be very clear for you so typically
you know maybe it's not you know it'd be
very difficult to do it very straight
quantitative as if you have an anti but
it has extremely low binding efficiency
it may not be the best clone to be using
in the first case but as far as being
able to detect over background that you
should have no issues whatsoever
okay our next question do does all of
you have solutions for the
co-registration of multiple rounds of
imaging and there's two parts or is this
dependent on your imaging equipment or
image analysis software so we do so
that's why some of our technology is
still brought in-house especially for
our higher levels of flexing we do have
software that we can actually do our Co
registration for of reimaging the same
slide and then aligning those specific
images as far as the systems that we can
take or you know image type files that
we can take we're pretty flexible as far
as that goes you know like I said before
to work with the axial scan and the
verse of the device to do these types of
stacking and dr. Patel how do you deal
with tissue autofluorescence so tissue
autofluorescence as a you know that's
something that could have a very good
question that something that comes up on
a very regular basis with our assay our
signal the background is so high that
you do not worry about autofluorescence
our exposures tend to be extremely low
in the fitzy channel and even like you
notice i-5 and across the across the
board actually that you're minimizing
the amount automatically come up so
there is no need to actually go ahead
and do you know auto floor removal we've
done standing of you know things like
liver tissue things like that that
actually tend to have very high auto
fluorescence but the signal is so clear
and so high that you do not worry about
missing any positive cells
so many questions coming in I just want
to remind our audience that any
questions we do not have time to get to
today dr. Patel will answer these via
email following the presentation okay
our next question how does the
sensitivity compared to TSA based
signals so as far as the sensitivity
goes so with our assay specifically you
know we use a linear amplification
pyramide based assays do not they use
more of a geometric type amplification
and also keep in mind when you're using
tear amides they actually deposit
pyramids around the epitope of interest
so which actually leads to issues of
co-localization and that when you're
doing a multiplex assay specifically
you're actually you know say you're
doing three or four markers for example
you're doing amplification of each one
of your tear amides at a different
position at a different time
so they're not happiness and they also
happen at a different rate because as
you can imagine if you're using a rabbit
and then a mouse primary antibody in the
20-year rounds you're using different
secondary antibodies that do that
detection and do that amplification
methodology and when you're doing using
an amplification methodology that's not
linear you tend to run towards
saturation and it's very difficult to
compare so with our assay we're
extremely sensitive because all targets
we have fight at the same rate same time
and if being linear you avoid the issue
of being able to running into the issue
of over saturation of an epitope so now
you can truly see differential
expression of a single marker on a
single cell or from cell to cell where
if you hit saturation you're really only
doing phenotyping at that point you
can't really do a quantifiable type
analysis of saying one is a high
expressive versus a low expressor
what would be the minimum requirements
to have a custom este develop so to do
custom assay development so that's a
great question as well and you know
custom panels for that you know it
depends on the number of plaits this is
a very complicated question but I'll
give you a brief overview of all we need
to what we usually need to consider you
know if you would also have to consider
the number of Plex that you're
interested in doing we've worked with
well over forty markers plus and within
our services group here so we actually
have quite the library what you really
need to do is have a good primary
antibody ideally you know like a
clinically relevant clone or something
that's been well published something
that you know has extremely good
staining patterns it's a good high
performance primary antibody we need
that in high concentration and carrier
free and then you know good control
juice to really base that are stating
off of and that's that's really where we
start so you know good quality antibody
in high concentration that's carrier
free
dr. Patel what tumor sample types have
you optimized staining protocol so what
do we actually do or when we're actually
developing any of our kits we actually
stay in a large variety of tumor types
both stain
colon melanoma breast tissue oral
cancers lung cancers a variety of those
types we've optimized our kit across a
variety of tissue types under variant
types of fixation processes at what have
you there keep in mind this these are
all pre optimized so no matter what your
fixation methodology was or what type of
tissue you're looking at this assay is
optimized to run the way is you know
right out of the box for that specific
tissue type and we also work with a
variety of different cell lines in
circulating white blood cells as well to
run as controls
we're very large on you know developing
the robustness and the validity of our
our assay across a variety of different
types of tissues and controls
next question we just like a recap all
of you is a kit and a software or does
one need a specific microscope so also
views kits there you know those are the
commercial kids are really available you
do not need a specific type of
microscope really what you need is a
hold any type of you know relatively
run-of-the-mill whole slide scanner that
can look at you know about five
different colors so that can visualize a
Dappy a fitzy at RIT CSI five and a size
seven Society seven may be something
that may be a little bit more specific
to a handful of whole slide scanners
that are out there but that's really it
you don't need anything that has any
sort of spectral and mixing capabilities
or anything like that
okay dr. Patel is there any additional
care that should be taken while
preparing slides for IHC is frozen our
frozen section compatible so we have not
worked with fresh frozen samples yet
it's not today it doesn't work we
haven't just worked with them
specifically as far as care as far as
samples go I mean you know generally
speaking you know you want to float
follow the general rules of thumb when
you're doing you want good fixation you
don't want to over fixate your tissues
ideally you want really fresh samples
that were you know paraffin-embedded
very quickly and efficiently and they
were stored under the appropriate
conditions so nothing different besides
that we don't need any other types of
specific prep like I said I think one of
the beautiful parts of our assay is that
it's very robust and it's able to handle
a variety of different types of tissue
and of different types of tissue quality
and still give you good solid
performance
are there any plans to develop kits for
preclinical species
so all of our kids now are really you
know their research use only so they're
really in the preclinical space but if
maybe you're referring to maybe Mouse
tissues or Mouse panel specifically if
that if that's the case that there are a
lot of talks that we've had about that
we've worked with humanized mice already
internally with our services group and
our kid should work just fine and those
types of tissues but if that's something
that you are interested in doing our
services group would be happy to take on
projects that are surrounding a mouse
tissue specifically
okay dr. Patel are you developing panels
to other indications
yeah so we're constantly building new
kits and new panels so obviously right
now we have the PDL one and PD kits
which are kind of specific to a couple
bit of specific types use cases but are
we also have our Tea Act APC kits that
are also available you'll be seeing a
quite a few new ones coming out this
year so stay tuned in ideal it will
probably have another six to seven
within the year that you'll see and
they'll have varying levels of more
generalized immune panels and some will
be maybe a little bit more specific as
you're alluding to
what clones are being used for cd8 cd68
PDL one-pan CKD kits and other
commercially available kits yep so for
as far as that information goes that's a
lot to kind of go over we can we can
send you that information afterwards so
if you'd like to drop some email or
what-have-you and we can catch you that
kind of information when you discuss
with one of our FAS is or one of our
sales people we can talk about that but
one thing I would like to mention too is
that we take clone selection extremely
seriously here at Ulta view that when
we're actually designing our specific
panels we're looking for clinically
relevant clones to bring in if
clinically relevant clones are
unavailable or maybe there isn't even
one available out there we will be we do
strong literature literature research to
understand the most widely used clones
that are most widely accepted through
publications we also very cute very
large key opinion leader network and
work with a lot of different
collaborators and we get all of their
input as voice of customer to really
understand which clones are ideal to use
for all these specific type cases
in addition to antibodies do you have
RNA scope probes in your kits no we do
not
okay our next question have you done
extensive calibration between cell
culture and digit ID results yes so
defining extensive would be it would add
a little clarity to that but we've
worked with cell culture lines in some
of our controls when we're doing assay
development to really understand how
well our assay is actually functioning
and working so if there's more to that
question I'd love to hear more about it
but what you mean as far as extensive
goes and you have to discuss that
offline
excellent now we have time for a few
more questions can your software outline
a lung metastatic lesion and enumerate
the intramural cell infiltration
enter to Merle I apology yes so as I
believe the customer if this person -
came that we did a higher level of
flexing and stained the same slide you
know if you've tried to a
co-registration of the same slide with
multiple markers so like an eight Plex
for example yes we can have to do that
co-registration without issue if it's
referring to serial sections maybe you
know two separate serial sections of
that lung tumor our software is not
designed to handle that but there are
other ones that are available in the
market that can do that I believe but
I'm not sure how how well that those
other software's outside of both of you
actually perform at doing that
this one is two parts how do you excite
the cy7
on a Zeiss Axio scan as I didn't believe
the l8 LED hit the peak excitation of
the fluorophores can you swap the floor
for so rather than see why have AC why
3.5
so for swapping fluorophore that's not
something we typically do when we pick
the fluorophore specifically just to
make sure everything there's spectral
isolation so you don't have any bleed
through a cross talk with our Axio skins
all our axial scans here that we run
that we run our actually size seven
enabled I believe Zeiss has two couple
of two different configurations we've
run with the spectra X which was kind of
their their predecessor system that they
had used to actually make their axial
skin size seven capable but they've
actually recently developed a Calibri
upgrade that is that they really own
that is available on their new
commercial systems that are there and I
believe they can upgrade systems that
are already on the field to be able to
do the size seven so if that's a simple
light source upgrade
dr. Patel ervis stained slides
archivable
so we are looking at the stability of
our stained tissue slides and right now
we've we've shown stability for over
eight months stored it in the dark at
four degrees so I'm not sure how long
the archival data would be good for past
that we're developing or we're
understanding how long these are good
for as time progresses
I know I've also had slides that I mean
basically carrying around with myself
for six months in my bag and they still
they still scan incredibly well and
that's also to keep in mind to it else
is a little bit depending on what type
of scanner you use to visualize these
our dyes are very stable they're very
robust so we don't run into a lot of
photo bleaching but if you're using an
older type scanner that is dumping full
amounts of flaking a white light
directly under the slide while scanning
you do run the risk of starting a photo
bleach which obviously would impact the
stability and the longevity of those
dyes for long time storage
can you dosed bar-coded antibody and
vivo and do analysis on section slides
did you repeat that question
to start it's written can you dost
bar-coded antibody and vivo and do
analysis on section slide
sure we've taken our we've done that yet
it'd be something interesting to look at
okay and how to overlap the two images
on slide number 10 automatically by
software
Oh yep so that so that autumn so that
was a basically a software tool we've
created internally to be able to do that
type of alignment so that's that's one
that's commercially available out there
but probably any serial sectioning
alignment software that's out there from
other other vendors can probably do the
same sort of thing
okay and we're almost at a time I'll
have to wrap with this final question
what is the highest level of flexing you
can do so at city of last year we
actually showed a 10 flex sorry 9 flex
10 color after that we actually did
staining for our services group could
routinely runs 8 if you come to see as
na da R or right after a ser we'll be
releasing some more information that
might pique your interest as to what our
new levels of flexing actually are and
so keep in mind as I said before you
know that the process that we use for
our staining is incredibly gentle it
does not you know degrade any the
tissues we don't do multiple rounds of
antigens retrieval it's a single step
and that we don't really run any into
any steric hindrance issues so we need
co-localization so the number of flexing
can get up there pretty quick
thank you for your time today thank you
for your extensive answering of our
questions I want to thank our audience
also for joining us and for their
interesting question those questions we
did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by dr. Patel
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration dr. Patel do
you have any final comments for our
audience I just want to say thank you
for taking the time to have a stare
today we appreciate the audience and we
look forward to your questions and come
see us at a ser if you get a chance
thank you again to dr. kachur Patel we'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Ulta view for underwriting
today's educational webcast today's
webcast will be available on demand and
laboratory via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you soon goodbye